Let's see.
Let's go next to our caller from the six to
three areaCode, who is calling today from
six to three.
Hello.
Yeah, that's you.
Oh, hi, this is Ricky from Phenix.
So I have a quest of sort of question, because
lately on your show you have been saying it
shouldn't be a taboo, talking about religion
and politics at the table.
Right.
So, yes, I've been trying to talk to people
like, you know, like at work and, you know,
my family, my friends of about politics.
And they get really super man.
So I'm just like, well, we should really have
a discussion now because it is kind of a bad
time.
So how would you approach that?
Well, what did they get like?
Give me an example.
So, Ricky, you decide to bring something up
with, like a family member.
What do you bring up and then how do they
respond?
So when the stimulus checks came in and Trump
had a letter with the stimulus checks come
in in the mail.
Yeah, they were like, oh, this is a nice thing
to do us like.
That's a big propaganda.
And they all got mad.
I mean, there are like less supporters, but
they don't know anything about politics.
So I just brought their personal identities
of their propaganda.
So here's an idea on that one.
That's a good that's a good one with the way
you might approach it would be instead to
try to get them thinking instead of saying,
don't you think that this is just propaganda?
You could say, that's interesting.
You know, everything the government does costs
money.
Do you think this is a good use of taxpayer
money to send these letters?
And then maybe they say, yeah, I do.
And then you say, OK, that's interesting.
How do you decide if something is a good use
of taxpayer money?
My point is it's not so much about which questions
you ask, but just get them thinking about
how they came to these conclusions.
Because I agree with you, this letter is is
totally propagandistic, but by starting to
call it propaganda, I probably won't convince
too many people.
Instead, if I get him to think about we have
limited funds, you know, if they care about
debt, say we're in debt, we have a pandemic.
This costs money like this.
You're saying this isn't it?
This is a good OK use of money when the money
could have gone to something other than sending
all of these letters out to people.
I would maybe approach it that way than just
calling it what?
By the way, I agree with you, it's propaganda.
But you probably aren't going to convince
too many people like that.
No, because, you know, I do say some things
and I do think I'm on the ball when I come
from my response to flight media kind of approach
to a different way.
Yeah, well, you know, I mean, it's good to
be thinking about it, about that.
Listen, Ricky, Arizona has one of the worst
corona virus case growth rates in the world
right now.
How are you living it down there?
Is it if my friends in Arizona are saying
it's like business as usual, just everything's
open and nobody's wearing masks.
Yeah, no, I worked at a Sam's Club, right?
Right.
I mean, I happen to have a massive policy
going on.
Everybody's going out freely.
Everybody's going to the gym.
It's really, really bad.
Like, I recently went on a day and we went
and we went to like a lake in my day.
And then nobody was wearing masks.
People weren't social distancing.
So it was kind of boring for us.
I mean, we did try to put a social distance
closer.
Like your friend said, it's business as usual
as though nothing was changing at all.
Are people even talking like our people?
So there's people who are not wearing masks
as if everything's fine and nothing's going
on.
There's also people who are sometimes not
wearing masks because they're aware of what's
going on, but they think it's like a hoax
or not not really a problem.
Which is it more of, would you say, people
who are just like on cloud nine and aren't
even aware or people who have decided, like,
I don't need to wear a mask right now?
It's it's I don't need to wear a mask.
I get the majority of people I talk to.
I don't need to wear a mask.
So.
Yeah.
Wow.
All right, Ricky, good luck down there in
Phenix.
Thank you and good luck.
I'm a fan of the show, I recently became a
member, so.
Thank you.
I appreciate that, too.
All right, Ricky, take care.
Great to hear from you.